the lease trotted out in the morning
there was a man with a camera and we had
a script girl sometimes almost never but
they would look around and say well what
are we gonna do the game where are we
going well there's a manhole cover over
here and we can do that site gag over
there and then we can go to Echo Park
and we can get a canoe and somebody said
yeah we could turn the canoe over and
she could look like she's drowning and
then the dog could save her yeah let's
do that okay we'll go to Echo Park it's
gonna be Judith you know that's how they
put supplies together and I remembered
those kind of days I hope that'll be
interesting you know and we do that and
nothing daunted me I wasn't frightened
the way it went I didn't like vaudeville
which I got into later because you did
the same thing every single day over and
over and over again you know this was
very creating the first fan it was
inspiring it was very refreshing and
creative and I like that I think from
the beginning I was very creative person
I went along with it perfectly you know
and subsequent was something that you
just did and you didn't do it twice you
didn't do the same thing twice because
that killed it a lot of the things that
the studios did was to try to promote
some talkies as the singing that was
good and they made out the silent era
was sort of a stone age of films and it
was really terrible because they they
talked them down and they deliberately
ran some of the other films fast and to
make them look corny you know and we
were often invited out those of us who
were veterans from silent films were
brought in for a sort of a publicity
stunt and to be there and the names were
very familiar they rang bells with the
audiences but they they were using us to
promote something that was to demote
ourselves and so I consider this and a
lot of people did also sort of a an
Allegiant of the walking dead you know
and I was a youngest member because I
was only 14 a lot of the technology was
what really was wrong and the people
didn't have bad voices most of the
people even in silence were recruited
from the stage so they had good voices
and some of them over shot over talks
were too strong I walked to school in my
everyday and I used to see the backyards
and they had these these incinerators to
burn all the trash in those days and so
there would be stacks of photographs
I couldn't mistake but they were you
know and they were black from the fires
that were they were going to go in next
and then there were a few scenes of
films and I'm walking along there and it
was like watching the world it was like
the revolution in France for something
this was all going right fast and it was
dead and so I had to go through the
trauma of believing what the studio's
were saying that our pictures were no
damn good you know they'd never been any
good and so I told myself I never really
want to see a baby Peggy picture as long
as I live they must have been dreadful
and so the other evening when I was
sitting through the big parade and
thinking about that I remembered so many
theatres that I said and installed
wonderful films so I thought I must have
dreamed that or maybe because I was a
child I didn't understand but I was
right you know but it was a trauma for
me and I didn't know that other adults
were going through the same thing I was
going through Mary Pickford was gonna
burn all of her films you know and
Reginald Annie was filled by an English
interviewer that we're gonna run out of
your films and he said oh no no I don't
want to see one he had the same trauma
you